bonjour vincent berger merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france au niveau
juridique qu'est ce que cette nouvelle
convention change c'est surtout au
niveau de la peine de mort que ce n'est
plus pareil ou bien ce que ça va plus
loin
alors c'est un texte qui n'est pas en
vérité très important il est surtout
important point de vue sur le plan des
symboles puisque l'algérie depuis 1993
observe un moratoire sur la peine de
mort puisque la peine de mort fait
partie de son code pénal
donc les tribunaux algériens continuent
de temps en temps à condamner des
personnes à la peine de mort mais celle
ci n'est pas exécutée et en plus la
gérer en décembre 2020 a voté une
délibération résolution de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies qui appeler à
un moratoire ou à une abolition générale
de la peine de mort donc c'est plus
important sur le plan jeu je le répète
des principes que de peu de
l'application effet pied entre 2014 et
2019 il ya eu 38 demande d'extradition
finalisé 30 vers paris 8 vers alger ces
chiffres vont ils augmenter avec ce
nouveau texte ou est-ce que ça de voir
un jour j'ai pas l'impression que ça
changera grand chose c'est une
compréhension importantes comme je leur
ai je viens de dire sur le plan des
principes mais en pratique ça ne devrait
pas changer grand chose pourquoi parce
que la france depuis déjà longtemps
parfois extract des personnes vers des
pays où ils risquent la peine de mort
par exemple vers les états unis
d'amérique la une soit qu'elles aient
les états unis ont donné des assurances
selon lesquelles et personne ne serait
pas exact la même chose vis à vis de la
russie
lorsque la russie a adhéré au conseil de
l'europe dont les années 90 elle a pris
l'engagement d'abolir la peine de mort
la peine de mort existe toujours dans le
code pénal russe et des tribunes russe
continue de prononcer la peine de mort
mais depuis fort longtemps de plus de 20
ans maintenant la peine de mort n'est
pas exécutée en russie donc on se trouve
à peu près dans la même genre de
situation c'est à dire que la france
prend la précaution de dire
nous n'excluons traduiront personnes
vers un pays où il ya un risque réel
d'exécution la peine de mort donc tous
repose en réalité sur les assurances
diplomatiques du pays sur la confiance
que l'on fait dans le gouvernement de
l'état signataire d'une convention
d'extradition proie abdel-majid tebboune
le président algérien at il attendu
jusqu'à maintenant pour ratifier ces
textes
alors qu'emmanuel m'apprend lui l'a fait
en mars qu'est-ce que ça traduit
politiquement alors je ne sais pas ce
que ça traduit peut-être qu'il ya eu tes
y at-il eu des hésitations en algérie vu
la dégradation des relations entre les
deux pays depuis déjà un certain temps
et il est possible que au contraire
cette ratification constitue un signe de
bonne volonté qui finalement ne coûte
pas très cher aux autorités algériennes
la justice européenne autorise également
depuis la fin avril
la france a expulsé vers l'algérie un
condamné pour terrorisme
là aussi qu'est ce que ça se change on
sait que la cour européenne la
jurisprudence de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme bloquer les expulsions
vers alger en raison d'actes de torture
alors là ce qui peut changer c'est que
peut-être que cette personne si elle est
mal traitée dans son pays d'origine pour
à faire une requête contre la france
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
mais on n'en est pas là de toute façon
c'est là il y aura toujours ce contrôle
de la cour de strasbourg sur les actions
d'états parties comme la france qui sont
liés par la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme merci vincent berger
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris et spécialiste en relations
internationales